hey y'all do you love middle ground
i know i do did you know that every
purchase made at the jubilee shop helps
fund this show if you're looking for
ways to support jubilee and watch more
episodes of middle ground make sure you
check out our merch at
shop.jubileemedia.com
honestly every one of your purchases
goes such a long way and we're so
grateful for you i enjoy this episode
i don't have science to prove why i
believe what i believe it's just
astrology has not led me wrong is there
a way you can tell if you're wrong or
right well yeah because psychology i
speak to my clients
[Music]
i'm ian i'm an adventure astronomer and
astrophotographer what i love about
astronomy is sharing the passion of the
stars with people i question science all
the time that's the whole point about
science when i hear of astrologers i
think of people who
kind of need guidance astrology is not a
science science is something that
requires proof something that you can
reproduce i think astrology is just a
belief system and i don't think it makes
sense it's not really a science i
honestly believe that astrology just
makes people happy
hi my name is trenton i am a spiritual
analyst i definitely believe astrology
is a science we have discovered so much
about the metaphysics of things and
energies that are hidden i think my
study benefits people because
the greatest gift that you can give
someone is self-knowledge it gives us
our own little map of ourselves i
believe that zodiac signs are totally
relevant but they're just a basis of a
much deeper practice they're the tip of
the iceberg
step forward if you agree
astrology is a sham
you believe whatever you want to believe
in as long as you know it makes you
happy doesn't hurt others um but
personally i've just never really
understood how especially since we both
we all study stars how something that's
so far away and that could potentially
be gone
could affect you when you were born it
just doesn't make sense to me
scientifically one of the things that
they don't account for astrologers is as
time passes by there's this thing called
procession where the where the earth's
axis actually makes like a rotation
and
these constellations were set like 2
000 years ago and they still assume that
these are the ones that are where you're
where the sun is when you were born and
also you can't split them apart equally
because each constellation has different
sizes they don't you don't have the sun
in one for 30 days you just don't do
that
and
look let's be honest you can't divide
people into these neat categories
there's almost eight billion people on
this planet you're going to tell me that
there's only 13 categories of what we
got what we are exactly it doesn't make
sense right i think sham is kind of a
it's a negative word but
from a scientific standpoint we don't
see that there's evidence that we can't
make predictions on people's lives based
on
the positions of the stars
can the disagreers come forward
[Laughter]
i practice western tropical astrology
and so the tropical system of astrology
goes off of the equinoxes and the
solstice it has nothing to do with the
constellations what you know of
astrology in the western world i'm also
specialized in tropical astrology and
that's just one system in astrology
right there's tropical insiderial those
are the two systems and they're
separated by 23.4 degrees it all depends
on what system works for you so does
that mean you have like a choice or you
like you see what everything means and
you're like okay i want to pick that one
i want to study um it's based off of
what really resonates right and you'll
know what resonates with you you'll get
this inner feeling through your chakra
system
and you'll know right away whether you
resonate with vedic astrology or western
astrology depends on
whether you're more interested on using
astrology for predictions or whether
you're more interested
on using astrology to understand
yourself and validate and affirm the
things that you feel in yourself you say
astrology meaning that
the stars do matter
right so what part do stars play in
western tropical astrology it's not so
much being born around the time that the
constellation is in a certain place in
the sky you have this chart wheel and
it's divided equally in 12 parts so the
rising would be dependent on that wheel
what
sign and not constellation but what sign
depending on the tropical divisions is
on the eastern horizon then the rising
is the first house or it's the cusp of
the first house and there's 12 houses
what does that mean because i hear that
and again i'm not familiar with it it
just kind of sounds like a lot of
gibberish yeah absolutely if you think
of a clock the hands pointing to the
numbers is not time they just represent
time so it's the same when you think of
the stars the planets where they are in
the chart are not the energies that
we're looking at they're just rep
representations of those energies it's
just the realm of possibilities that the
way that you express action in your life
could show up
when we categorize different planets in
astrology it's just to give
characteristics on the specific energies
to touch on a point that you brought up
like how can we be here and planets all
the way out there how are they affecting
us energy cannot be created or destroyed
right we all heard that in our science
classes growing up so we are all bits
and that's not necessarily true this is
like essentially you're talking about
like kind of kind of conservation of
energy and stuff like that right but
like we live in a universe that for
example may be infinite yeah we don't
know and we and we never can because so
because we're we're limited to a
specific distance to how far we can see
i guess what i was getting to is we're
all bits and pieces of energy so
everything that exists in our universe
is energy i think that we're getting
confused with our definitions of energy
i think that's where the like we have a
different definition of like more
scientific definition of energy and you
guys have more of uh it's it's like a
personality like especially yeah like
that yeah i think there's uh
for science like they they have to be
very careful about how they use the term
energy because a lot of the times it can
get hijacked or even delving into the
world with like quantum physics they use
the word quantum in a way that it's not
supposed to be represented as
my beliefs are supported by science
so
you guys are probably like astrology
it's not a science uh but it is because
it's it's its own separate um field
astrology has been a practice that has
been used for civilization what is
science to you what does science mean to
you now a science is anything that can
be applied to the practical realm i know
we were saying a lot of talk about oh
this is interpretive or this could be
used for predictive measures but it is
something that is practical right i have
to use math and i have to use other
basic science skills in order to pull up
a chart i'm looking at degree placement
right i think that
fields could use
science and still not be science you
could use math and science and it'd
still not be a science um i think
science comes to a degree i'm sorry
what's your definition of science i
think science is
comes with fact there's a scientific
method so you start with a theory and
then you prove it at the end say we
randomly discover a new planet in our
solar system okay will it change which
you guys absolutely because that would
that would be something that we'd have
to sit and try to study we'd have to uh
conduct a research on that planet just
as well as you guys would have to do you
guys would just be applying it in a
different way so i definitely look at
our fields as a science
are my beliefs
backed by science no they're not in fact
it's the opposite
most scientists would say that i'm crazy
do i believe that astrology is a type of
science a soft science yes because i
study psychology i study therapy there
are people who say that therapy and
psychology are not sciences
i also think that psychology and therapy
are soft sciences they're not rooted in
the scientific method they are rooted
more in the person
in who that person is and the potential
of that human being and their energies
but there's a difference there because
in psychology we could see we could scan
the brain and see the chemical
imbalances we could see what's missing
we could see the neurons firing we could
see exact
exactly why things are happening and we
could prove that so but you can't always
give the treatment but we can also look
at a chart we can also look at a chart
and look at how the energies are
interacting with a person and correlate
it to what is on the chart i think
energies and like neurons
i keep using energies and that's also
what i'm trying to say somebody had to
be like
why is that why is that energy affecting
me in this way somebody had to sit and
study these things somebody a team had
to do research on these things i don't
have science to prove why i believe what
i believe it's just i've been studying
this for seven years and i've been
practicing professionally for four years
and i
astrology has not led me wrong like i
start i don't miss is there a way you
can tell if you're wrong or right well
yeah because
i speak to my clients i never tell my
clients like this definitely happened
for you and if you don't agree then
you're wrong i'll say oh this could be
an indication of this is this true and
they'll say yes or if they say no i'll
say well maybe it can be interpreted in
this different way that's also where the
interpretive thing comes in is that it
doesn't play out the exact same
every time which is why it can't be
pinned down and that's why you can't
call it a science it's not reproducible
science is something that
is rigorously tested and it's stuff
that's reproducible you have to be able
to reproduce results and what astrology
is is interpretive
so you might misinterpret things because
it's not really reproducible like you're
not going to always get somebody right
the reason why i didn't step forward for
this prompt was because i think it's
irrelevant like i think beliefs are
different than facts and you know i
might really believe in god for example
i might right um and that's not backed
by science you know science is science
right so it doesn't matter if i believe
astronomy doesn't matter what i believe
it just is or isn't
celestial objects influence people's
mood
i mean if i'm driving home maybe i had a
bad day and i see the moon coming up
it's so beautiful like how can that not
affect your mood right it's just so
gorgeous i do a lot of astronomy
outreach you know i show people the
planets or the moon through telescopes
or total solar eclipse that we've seen
we were all like
in tears it was just so beautiful so yes
definitely things that happen up there
can affect you know how the moons affect
uh bodies of water right the closer the
moon is the higher the waves are the
farther away it is the lower the waves
are right that's why we have tides kind
of sort of right um but we're made up of
70 water the moon in astrology talks
about our intuition our feelings our
emotions there are so many other planets
and celestial bodies that are definitely
doing that so i'm so happy
that you said yes because it is
definitely true
i'd love to know what you think about
the correlation between the 28-day cycle
of the moon and the female hormonal
cycle there must be something there i'm
not an evolutionary biologist i don't
really know yeah i'm a cancer rising so
i feel
the moon and i know from personal
experience that yeah planets affects the
moon
i'll have to say i really liked your
interpretation of that
because you know one i mean the moment
that you stepped up i was like okay i
know what's coming
i know i know what it is because i do
agree on that
i mean look mars is really far away what
is mars gonna do like you know to
to my mood it just it just it just
doesn't even the gravitational force
that we that we experience between
planets that are further away it's just
it's really nothing
can i ask what makes you say that with
such certainty because i'm
i
do physics and so i know what like how
gravity like the force of gravity works
sure but we have plenty of um
anecdotal i guess you could say evidence
well the thing is if you believe
something right mm-hmm
like you already believe it and then the
thing that you i i really have to
mention this like the thing that you
mentioned about the correlation between
like women's periods and
and the moon the moon is moving away
from us so eventually it's not going to
orbit in the scene right right in the
same way and so
what then
i think there's a big thing right now
that we're using between correlation and
causation i think that's another big
divide that we're seeing right now like
when people
are like in a mood or like they're
really happy and they go outside they're
like oh
there's mars or the moon is full or
whatever that doesn't make sense to me
where people can kind of not blame their
behavior but associate it with
what's happening there's a correlation
but we can't see the causation of it
right
that goes back to my um my argument that
i posed earlier about how energetically
things are affecting us we're affected
by this energy
even if it's so many light years away or
if it's right here in front of us right
okay now what if what if i were to tell
you that let's say you know um
betelgeuse is what was like 400 light
years away 600 light years away if we
saw beetlejuice go supernova right some
astrologers might say oh my gosh that's
that's you know affecting us that
happened 600 years ago right so why is
it affecting me now like you know what
i'm saying yeah everything that you see
like if it's something that's four light
years away you're seeing it as it was
four years ago right not as it is today
i only can go off of planets that are
actually like
like in orbit like the moon the sun our
basic uh planets including pluto um
those are the only things that i really
focus on so let's just let's just go
back to mars and say venus right because
mars is has all these like really rough
and
angry qualities or whatever burning you
guys
and venus has all these beautiful common
peaceful qualities but what if i were to
tell you that if you were to go into
venus and sit and sit there you wouldn't
even make it because the pressure would
just destroy you so why how is that how
is that peaceful and you know like what
is that like where does this come from
there are no good and bad plans i just
want to live there there's a highest
expression and there's a lowest
expression mars is not evil it can
represent aggression it can represent
anger it can also represent action and
motivation venus is yet love
relationships beauty it can also be
manipulation like there's no oh this is
a bad planet this is a good planet like
there's levels here there's duality
there's highest expression there's
there's i just wanted to because like
me and the plan is like their mom
let's listen
i believe in zodiac signs and their
predictions
i definitely do believe in zodiac signs
and their predictions and what they
could bring and it all depends on how
you're tracking the energy how you're
also communicating whatever it is that
you can get from the energy to a client
that's basically what my job is as an
interpretive astrologer is to break down
what i see on the chart and to
communicate it in a way that you would
understand
i just like was hesitant about coming up
with predictions because yeah it's the
word predictions i i'm not of the belief
that astrology is necessarily a science
because i don't consider myself a
scientist
and
astrology is such an interpretive
practice that using astrology as a
predictive tool
sometimes does more harm than good it
can create a lot of anxiety and
sometimes it is inaccurate you're going
to get human error in some sort of
interpretation i have a lot of friends
and a lot of people around me who
believe in um astrology um but my thing
is i've had so many of them be like
what's your star sign so i always tell
them well guess what do you think i am
and then it always ends up being wrong
or like i'll finally tell them
afterwards and i'll be like i'm this and
they're like that's so virgo of you that
doesn't make sense to me um so that's
why i don't personally believe in those
star signs i know that you guys discuss
that but that's why i don't disagree
with what you guys said um but that's
why i disagree with the prompt that was
read out with sun star astrology or
sunshine astrology that's where it can
get carried away it's actually the
rising that's most important because
that starts your chart what the sun
represents is our own sense of self and
when you first meet someone at a party
how much are you going to be able to
know off the bat from your first
impression of them what their sense of
self is exactly what i
think is that because we live in a world
where we don't know people at all if you
have a way to be able to somehow
describe who this person is when you
just first meet them it makes you feel
safe and that's why i feel like
you know a lot of people take to
astrology people
like they think astrology puts them in a
box like oh you're a capricorn this is
the only way you can behave this is the
only way you connect it's like no
astrology is very much about the
possibilities not necessarily this is
what you are this is what you do this is
how you act i don't like you no it's
just like this is what could possibly
happen this is the expression you could
possibly take would you say that
everyone has like all possibilities are
available for everybody yes
well i mean to a certain extent even if
you are like say a virgo son your virgo
son could be
affected by a certain relationship with
say mars so it's not like you're just
this and you can only be this it's like
no you've got this you've got a you know
sprinkle of something of this it's
people don't like me putting in boxes
which makes sense but that's totally not
what we're i don't think we're doing it
does though kind of sound like you're
you're still compartmentalizing things
to the point of like there are seven
billion eight billion people in the
world how can you categorize them in
these boxes but the deeper that you go
into astrology the more nuanced it gets
and the more personalized it gets
the other side doesn't fully understand
the study of celestial objects
i'm so of two minds about this
you guys are doing something that's very
scientific and uh practical in what
you're studying but just because
something isn't practical or scientific
you can still study religion you can
still study the bible
the torah i don't even think it should
necessarily be equated to your study for
like astronomy like their scientific
rigor into how we understand and how we
know what we know now you know standing
on the shoulders of giants all the
people who have studied it before us and
now we know and we can prove what
they've studied is correct it's very
like
factual i'm from my point of view as an
astrologer like i'm like yeah no things
are definitely factual based and like
astrologers sat down and they they've
come to a common consensus of what
things mean based off of where they're
placed what energies are placed on them
that's what gives them more of the
component of what the planet may mean i
think again that's where the divide is
because you guys could think certain
things are fact but i hear you keep
bringing up that it's interpretation
there's so many things going on way far
away that we know about that like you
said you don't really have
the necessity to know about i think that
there's a lot of stuff that you guys
interpret that we've disproven in a way
or that we've seen evidence for just
going completely against it negating
your guys's points um so i think that's
kind of where that divide kind of comes
from
one is the loneliest number
[Laughter]
yeah i would never
sit here and say that you know
like you don't know what you're talking
about but also like i don't think you
can fully understand anything i think
you can go to school i think you can do
the work i think you can have a very
good grasp on something but you can
never fully like we're talking about the
stars and the universe and the planets
here you can't fully understand
nothing in regards to that you read the
stars you read the cosmos you understand
all of the science-y things you said
beale just i was like the character
[Laughter]
for me as an astrologer i study the
stars yes but i also study people my job
is to work with someone one to one i'm
showing you what i see but i'm also
showing you what i see from you as a
person would you say astrology is along
more along the lines of like human
psychology psychology yes absolutely
okay depending on the system that you
are studying yeah definitely it kind of
means like that what yes what astrology
is is like for fulfillment in terms of
what benefits humankind i mean
physics astronomy literally brings us
you know cell phones that's practical
but we also as human beings like to have
things like art for example music i need
music if i didn't have music then i
might you know so it's kind of like
there's a fulfillment thing and i i i
would i i get that my belief is that
balance is extremely important and the
way i see it like logic and science and
all of these things are one
end of a spectrum like to get a little
spiritual it's like yang energy and
we're representing in my opinion a bit
more of the yin energy the human element
and i think that it's also important to
do what you can on a person-to-person
basis and that will help humanity
great thank you so much and that's a
wrap
we didn't kill each other
[Music]
you